welcome to the program we have seen
enough
joseph r biden jr will be
the president-elect of the united states
defeating donald trump the race has been
called by decision desk
hq others are starting to call
the race individuals familiar with
particular
states are making it clear that in
those states there will be no turning
back that joe biden's leads including
newfound leads that appeared overnight
will sustain and at this point in time
we are not saying donald trump will
concede anything
there is no doubt whatsoever that donald
trump is going to be filing lawsuits and
trying to get recounts and there will be
some recounts but
because joe biden has taken leads now in
multiple states and leads have grown
in other states joe biden is poised to
be
the presumptive winner of the
presidential race and we can say that
with
some comfort at this point in time so
let's take a look
at some of the numbers the latest
numbers in the key uncalled states
reminder alaska is still not called it
will not matter
in the end in nevada as the vote has
continued to trickle in
from 75 to 80 85 now 86 reporting at the
last batch of votes
joe biden's lead growing by a few more
votes now
to 21 20 and a half thousand votes in
nevada
there is every indication based on the
overwhelming amount of votes left
from the las vegas area which votes for
joe biden
that the lead will grow that alone would
be enough to get joseph r biden jr to
270 electoral votes
in arizona the vote continues
to come in and there is no credible path
for donald trump to retake the lead
remember that arizona was called by both
the associated press and fox news a
couple of days ago
donald trump insisting they should keep
counting the votes of course
that's what we do in elections we keep
counting the votes and they've continued
to count the votes
and it does not appear as though that
will be reversed
pennsylvania overnight flipping
from donald trump to joe biden it
started two days ago
as an eight-point lead for trump they
knew the mail-in votes would be counted
over time
and as that happened the lead for joe
biden shrank
i'm sorry the lead for donald trump
shrank from eight to seven six
five four three two last night it went
below one it went to below half a point
this morning it was tied and with the
latest
edition of votes joe biden has now taken
a lead
of about 98 hundred votes in
pennsylvania because of what is left to
count
experts in pennsylvania say there is no
path
for donald trump to retake that lead
in georgia donald trump has lost his
lead
slowly diminishing from a few points
to half a point to a tie
as of right now statistically 49.4 for
each candidate
although when you go one more digit you
see that joe biden does have a slight
lead there
of about 1800 votes and so any
combination
understand that nevada alone does it for
joe biden
nevada experts say nevada is done but
were he not to get nevada
and even if he were to lose arizona
pennsylvania alone
would put joe biden over 270. this makes
north carolina which has not
gone either way yet irrelevant
essentially
of course if joe biden maintains georgia
he also wins if he gets georgia but not
pennsylvania he needs certainly to
maintain
arizona or nevada and of course
if things end as they are now we don't
know if they will but if they do
joe biden will end up with 306 electoral
votes
more electoral votes than donald trump
had in 2016
and a massive absolutely
massive popular vote victory as
of right now the popular vote is uh in
joe biden's favor by 2.7 percent which
because of the very high turnout is
nearly
4 million votes uh just shy of that at
about 2.96
million votes right now just shy of that
for 3.96 rather just shy of a four
million vote margin
it will be a historic popular vote
margin
for joseph r biden jr one last
uh sort of element to look at
the current count per the new york times
in pennsylvania uh matching up with that
of the associated press
a slight joe biden lead in georgia
a very slight joe biden lead north
carolina
is still with no new reporting and we
are not expecting any new reporting for
some time
has joe biden down 1.4 percentage points
but we do not expect it to matter
arizona the new york times has not
called but the numbers
remaining in joe biden's favor and then
again as i mentioned in nevada
with the latest update joe biden
now with a 20 or so thousand
vote lead there so ladies and gentlemen
it is happening it is happening now we
are not
out of the woods in the sense of we
still don't have senate results
we still don't know what's going on with
the house in total donald trump will get
recounts in some states he's filing
lawsuits in some states
he has gone completely out of his mind
and he is unlikely to concede insiders
are saying
trump will not concede now don't worry
because concession is not a legal
process concession is a formality
where normal people when they lose say
i concede my opponent has won they call
their opponent
in ideal times you issue a message of
unity
not that i liked these people but john
mccain in 2008
had to silence the booze from his
sycophants to say
barack obama is a good man we both love
this country we are with barack obama
george h.w bush when he lost in 1992 to
governor bill clinton
issuing again doesn't mean we're saying
he's a great pr
was a great president he wasn't but he
behaved like a normal person
he behaved like a normal person even
hillary clinton
in 2016 despite donald trump saying you
would be in jail if i was president
conceded despite donald trump's claims
to the contrary
so we are going to be paying very close
attention over the next few days
to whether there is violence uh to how
the
uh vote counts continue coming in on
today's program we will be speaking
about
everything from sean hannity saying they
need to
redo the pennsylvania election
trump adviser stephen bannon saying dr
anthony fauci
should be beheaded yes yes he said that
uh and so much more but the big news is
the presumptive we are not yet saying
president-elect
the presumptive winner of the 2020
presidential election is joe biden now
in advance of what i know will be some
disappointment
that biden didn't win by more uh and
that the senate
and house aren't looking great we are
going to talk
about the problems on the left that led
to
what should have been a blowout not
being a blowout but it's not just the
left it's also
the right there is a lot to discuss and
i don't want to shortchange that
conversation so let's
not do it right now but what i do want
to remind people is
this is the removal of an incumbent
president it is very difficult to remove
an incumbent president
bill clinton did it to george h.w bush
in 1992 that was a three-way race ross
perot was in that one there were
additional factors complexities etc
it is not common that you remove even
a bad incumbent president so we have to
remember when we look at the numbers
incumbent president loses by 4 million
that is a big deal it doesn't excuse the
failings of the democratic party
it does nothing it doesn't excuse the
fact that nearly 70 million trumpists
said let me vote for four more years of
that
that's horrifyingly scary but the
important thing to remember
is that removing an incumbent president
is really difficult
i expect we will see more calls by the
networks over the next few hours
donald trump did speak yesterday and
we're going to have video of that he
gave a completely delusional
humiliating press briefing saying
everything is fake everything is fraud
claiming victory
donald trump jr took to twitter and said
that they need to go into total war mode
which i'm worried will lead to violence
we had questions throughout the day
yesterday why does trump want to stop
counting states that he's losing
if you stop counting when you're losing
you lose
we will find out about the incompetence
that was at play
there and we are even starting to see
some republicans and i'm not saying
they're good people because they're not
but some some republicans are even
jumping ship with trump's
authoritarianism saying
it's dangerous for him to claim victory
when he hasn't it's dangerous for him to
claim fraud when he has not presented
any actual
evidence of fraud and because we want to
have more good news today if possible
i will talk about the very bad news
about the pandemic
i will tell you about that 118 000 cases
yesterday
but on the good news the war on drugs
was
absolutely crushed crushed
on election day very interesting numbers
uh 2016 was not a fluke donald trump
and his coalition are still here and
they are very strong they almost got him
re-elected
but joseph r biden jr with multiple
paths
to 270 and now we can say the
presumptive winner
the race has been called by decision
desk hq
and i anticipate more calls very very
soon so glad you're with me
make sure you're following me on twitter
at deepakman make sure you're following
me on instagram at david.pacman
continued coverage
and much more one of our sponsors today
is
helix sleep and it's a sponsor i'm
thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might
have and they will pair you with a
mattress that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10 year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video